gina carano who you know used to be a
one of the earlier uh mma female mma
fighters
um obviously when she was fighting she
was
super hot i mean ridiculous she is
thicker now
but i don't care even thick gin or
carano
can get it like that's a fact
no one's gonna change my mind i do
understand that she was younger and
thinner
i don't care you don't gina carano gina
corona [ __ ] you
so let's start with that i like her i
thought she was [ __ ] fantastic i love
the mandalorians a great show
and i thought she was [ __ ] fantastic
in that show
pretty red pill talking about the mass
you should see the master stupid the
covet stuff is dumb
basically you know saying a lot of [ __ ]
that we say well gina carano said
something about
said that to the effect that republicans
are being treated like
uh using the host so
they decided that uh and look
they've been they've been angling for
months now we've talked about it in the
show before
they've been angling for months to
cancel her they've been trying really
hard
because you know she just wouldn't bow
down and wouldn't bow down and that's it
but you know she made that she made the
cardinal sin of
of criticizing and making making light
of
she can't do that i mean even though
senators and cnn and msnbc were
basically calling the capital riot
equivalent
and or worse to 911 that is a fact
they were saying those things that's not
me making it up they were saying it
they could say that that's fine but
don't imply
anything about the one that they talk
about not the armenian one the one that
the people refuse to refuse to talk
about
but you know the big boy one
so with that being said i saw this video
this morning i love the critical drinker
i think he does great i'm actually
working on getting him on the show
um which would be a lot of fun
i uh i saw this in this pro it's four
minutes it's worth watching
it's the critical drinker so obviously
subscribe to him but uh tell me what you
think
gather round dear viewer as i tell you a
tale
it's the tale of a woman who stood tall
in the face of jealousy
cowardice hatred and vengeance and dared
to utter a single word
no it's the story of the girl who
wouldn't back down
our story begins a long time ago in a
far-off land
with a young woman who decided to become
a warrior
now this was very unusual because few
women
chose such a path for themselves but she
was steadfast and determined to succeed
this young woman proved to be strong and
brave she fought and won many battles
and earned herself great acclaim
but the young woman had her eyes set on
a higher goal
and eventually she gave up her life of
fighting traveling instead to the great
kingdom of hollywood
to seek fame and glory as an actor
instead
and as it turns out her long years of
training and fighting served her well
and soon she was chosen for many roles
on the silver screen
her triumph was cemented when the king
and queen chose her to play a soldier
fighting amongst the stars themselves
her fame was growing fast
but sadly so was her list of enemies
for you see a dangerous cult was growing
within the kingdom
a sickness of the mind that preys upon
the weak
the hopeless and the pathetic turning
them into mindless zombies
unable to think for themselves any
longer they could do nothing but recite
the words of the cult leaders
and form into vicious mobs to attack
anyone who questioned them
all of the kingdom lived in fear of this
cult because few were brave enough to
challenge it
not even the king and queen with all
their wealth and power
because they depended on it to stay safe
in their big
comfortable castle and certainly not the
actors who were mostly self-absorbed
cowards
that cared only for applause and
approval in fact
most of them even pretended to be in the
cult themselves
because it's easier to sacrifice your
dignity and your principles
rather than stand your ground against
especially this [ __ ] [ __ ]
walking phoenix over here mr joker movie
mister everybody this is this panda's
the white supremacist this panders to
insults
that's what this joker does that's what
panders do and then he went up and he
did a stupid gay speech about unity and
[ __ ] and i don't know [ __ ] climate
change
some [ __ ] [ __ ] that he doesn't even
care about uh thank you atlas report
uh so [ __ ] him we [ __ ] walking phoenix
you look a great actor and the joker's a
great movie
but jesus christ it's the mob
but the young woman was different and
when the cultists
tried to turn her into one of them she
didn't just refuse their offer
she openly mocked them suddenly the free
people of the kingdom were laughing at
them
and their beliefs and their power was
shaken
the young woman had just become their
enemy an enemy that had to be destroyed
at
any cost again and again the mobs came
for her
well let's read some of these these are
good
no one is bullying you you shaded the
blm movement you've blocked people
commenting
uh it on your post if you're not racist
then prove us wrong because that looks
pretty racist to me prove us wrong
that that's the [ __ ] calm down royce
just relax your screaming's not going to
fix anything
you know that
that's my point when it comes to all of
this stuff
nobody owes you anything
no one needs to prove anybody wrong
like what you like don't like what you
don't like
if you don't like gina carano don't
support her don't watch the mandalorian
but you can't and look i love star trek
i like star wars
i know i said love and light because
there's a difference for me um
but these people their whole life is
star wars their whole life is harry
potter
it's like three things the three things
that define them
so instead of saying like but you can't
because you need to watch the
mandalorian
you need to watch it so instead of
shutting it off if you just don't like
her don't want to support her
now see there's a difference between me
and these people i can watch stuff that
people i don't like
make if they're good because i could i
could separate the art and the artist
like i can like
it's not difficult for me i'm sure 99
of the things that i watch on tv are
made by people
that are lefties and or are too scared
to say anything or pander to the left i
i get it
youtube the same thing that's just life
okay that that's life
but i don't care because if i watch
walking phoenix and the joker it doesn't
mean that i'm going to listen to
anything the [ __ ] actor has to say
about anything because i don't really
care
[ __ ] dance for me monkey i paid my 10
to watch the movie that's just the way i
look at it
uh not some more tweets here she really
thinks we were to create 12 fake
accounts just for her but anyways you
call people cowards
but who is the one blocking people for
calling you out on your racist
bootlicking behavior
ugh i'm sorry you're so triggered by
teens and adults calling out for being a
cop apologist and a racist
a cop apologist and a racist imagine
being a grown woman thinking you're
being bullied by a bunch of teenagers on
the internet
uh oh by the look it's not this is the
other thing
that's a misnomer and that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's not a bunch of
teenagers that are bullying you on the
internet because you go through these
profiles
and you go and see who these people are
and it's not a bunch of [ __ ]
teenagers
playing pokemon okay it's a bunch of
adults
it's a bunch of blue haired in their 30s
it's a bunch of [ __ ] guys making the
soy boy face
those are the people that are bullying
her don't don't [ __ ] pretend
don't [ __ ] pretend
that it's just a bunch of teenagers that
they're just being kids being kids
because it's not
and there's a lot of people that are
criticizing her don't even watch her
work
uh one uh man army two joker 2019 suck
like poo i liked it
the angry druid you should do a video
comparing hasbro gi joe to fast and
furious arguing gi
joe action is more realistic agreed with
you 100
uh calling you off for being a boot
licker isn't trolling gina it's calling
you out on being a bootlegger
all of these people are the same people
that if you were to
for even five seconds make a joke about
their preferred pronouns in their
twitter account
they would have your account nuked from
the planet they would [ __ ] use the
ronald reagan star wars system
to destroy you so you're never seen
again
uh i promise no one cares enough about i
may remember that uh
oh and by the way there's no trolls
everyone just hates you everyone does
not hate you
that's actually [ __ ] uh
oh no i'm gina carano i'm being bullied
by teenagers on the internet a [ __ ]
teenage
she these people the these [ __ ]
people man
but concert culture isn't real suck a
dick
to be destroyed at any cost again and
again the mobs came for her
but again and again they were beaten
back their rage and frustration
knew no bounds here was an enemy that
would not bend the knee to them
no matter how much they screamed at her
and could not be defeated
by even the fiercest mob an enemy that
threatened to expose them for the weak
frightened pathetic individuals they had
once been
and deep down they still were sensing
the growing power of the celts
and their ability to turn friends
families and neighbours into enemies
the young woman tried to warn the
kingdom of the threat they posed
she even gave examples of other evil
treasure beat in the streets not by
soldiers but by their neighbors even
children because history is edited most
people don't know and realize
to get to the point where these soldiers
could easily round up thousands of
the government first made their own
neighbors hate them simply for being
how is that any different than hating
someone for their political views
colts from other kingdoms who had once
done similar things
and in that decision lay her downfall
simply by naming them she had
inexplicably tied herself to them
in the eye hold on drinker
critical drinker is a smart dude
critical drinker's a smart dude
i want your verdict here on this
did he say naming them
because let's be realistic in 2021
when you say naming them we all kind of
know what you're talking about
i get it his channel's big he's always
700 000 subscribers almost
and i get it he wants to keep his
channel and good for him
but
i see what you did bud hey hey
you see what you did and i respect it
and i [ __ ] i i respect it buddy
that's all i i drink her i respect you
bud
decision lay her downfall simply by
naming them
she had inexplicably tied herself to
them in the eyes of the cult
she had exposed the [ __ ] in her armor
that they could exploit
and exploit it they did the greatest mob
the kingdom had ever seen
gathered at the gates of the castle
demanding the young woman's heads
and the king and queen desperate to stay
on their shiny throne
finally gave them what they wanted the
young woman was brought down
and handed over to the mob her so-called
friends had deserted her
the cult had won at last because no one
had the courage to stand against them
no one except the girl who wouldn't back
down
but the king and queen's reprieve would
be short-lived
for the people of the kingdom had seen
them for the cowards they were
and would no longer work to protect
their castle
in fact they turned their backs on them
by the thousands
leaving the kingdom far behind until at
last
the mob came for them as well too late
did they realize that if only they had
stood with the young woman when they had
their chance
all of this could have been avoided but
of course
this is just a story from an old drunk
it's not like something as sinister and
pathetic as this
could ever actually happen could it
anyway that's all i've got for today
go away now
they wrecked her [ __ ] career they
wrecked her life
and nobody nobody defends them i mean
look
obviously people like us and there's
other people online that defend them but
none of her peers will defend her now
that's it she's persona non grata
that's all she is now